>> Laura: DO TAKE BACK WHAT
YOUR EDITORIAL SAID IT MIGHT BE
GOOD FOR JEFF SESSIONS TO MOVE
ON, IN THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
WE'VE SEEN MORE LEAKS HAPPENING,
PERSON IS LEAKING THAT STUFF IT
>>
WAS PAYING HIM AND WE NEED A
IF THERE IS MOVEMENT ON THOSE,
FINE.
IF THAT'S WHAT I HOPE HAPPENED.
THERE SHOULD BE A NEW ATTORNEY
GENERAL, I LIKE JEFF SESSIONS
AND I WANT HIM TO DO HIS JOB.
I THINK WE TURNED A CORNER THIS
WEEK ON THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
TELLING US THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
GIVE US THE DOCUMENTS AND ACCESS
TO IMPORTANT WITNESSES.
>> Laura: HOW SIGNIFICANT IS
LINDSEY GRAHAM, THE FORMER JUDGE
ADVOCATE GENERAL THE LAWYER FOR
THE JAGGED CORE AND GRASSLEY
COMING OUT AND ASKING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO LOOK INTO
A POSSIBILITY OF A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO MR. STEEL?
THE ONE THAT HELPED GENERATE AND
SHEPHERD THROUGH THE FAKE
DOSSIER THAT COULD LEAD TO THE
OPENING OF THIS ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION.
>> I WANT TO SEE WHAT THEY WROTE
I WANT TO SEE WHAT COMES OF THIS
THEY ARE WANTING TO HAVE A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL FOR THE SKY,
THE AUTHOR OF THE DOSSIER WHO IS
BEING PAID BY THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN, IT'S REPORTED HE IS
BEING REIMBURSED BY THE FBI AT
THE SAME TIME.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S TRUE, I
THINK THIS IS CRITICAL AS ARE A
HOST OF QUESTIONS.
THINK ABOUT US -- WHY DID THE
TO RELEASE ANY INFORMATION
WAS THE OTHER 96%?
>> Laura: THE OTHERS MIGHT BE
RELATED TO HAVING A ROMANTIC
DINNER.
>> WHY DID THEY RELEASE ANY OF
THEM, AND IF SO WHY DID THEY
PICK THE 375 COME OUT DO WE SEE
THE OTHERS?
WHY DID LISA PAGE LEAVE THE
MOLAR
MUELLER TEAM -- THERE'S A HOST
OF QUESTIONS WE NEED TO GET
ANSWERS TO.
LET'S CALL THIS WHAT IT IS -- A
SHAM.
THIS IS A PHILANTHROPY THAT DOES
LIFE-CHANGING WORK WHICH
REPUBLICANS HAVE TRIED TO TURN
FORMER AIDE TO HILLARY CLINTON
DISTRACT FROM THEIR OWN TROUBLES
BY GINNING UP INVESTIGATIONS
INTO OLDER, SETTLED MATTERS.
>> I WISH THERE WAS ONE-TENTH OF
LEARNED IN THE LAST EIGHT WEEKS
RELATIVE TO CLINTON AND HOW THE
INVESTIGATION AND THE RUSSIAN
ISSUE.
ONE-TENTH OF THE INTENSITY OF
ALL OF THOSE AS THERE IS ON THE
MUELLER SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION.
NOT ONE BIT OF EVIDENCE SHOWS
WE KNOW TODAY THAT THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN PAID THE LAW FIRM WHO
PAID FUSION WHO PAID CHRIS
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION.
WE KNOW THE GUY WHO RAN THE
INVESTIGATION CHANGE THE
EXONERATION LETTER, WE NEED AN
INSURANCE POLICY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T RUN THE RISK THAT
DONALD TRUMP GETS ELECTED BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION, ONE-TENTH OF THAT
WAS APPLIED TO GETTING ANSWERS
TO ALL OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
ARISE FROM THAT FACT.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN ADAM
SHIFT A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK IS
LEADING INFORMATION OUT OF THE
CLOSE TOWARD SESSIONS.
LIKE DONALD JUNIOR HE WANTS TO
OBSTRUCTION CHARGE AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
SEQUENCE THEY WANT IF WE WOULD
JUST BE ABLE TO INTERVIEW LISA
PAGE, PETER STRUCK, JIM BAKER,
AND WHY WAS JIM BAKER REASSIGNED
TWO WEEKS AGO?
I WANT TO BRING THEM ON THE
WITNESS STAND AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS IN FRONT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> Laura: IT SEEMS LIKE THE